Wow mom thanks for letting me play this
game none of the other kids at school
were allowed to play this one you're the
best mom ever
sure honey you can play any game you
want hey honey did your friend mention
that the new Mortal Kombat movie is that
why there's another movie out I saw the
first one on TV one time he's okay I'll
take you to see it if you want you'll
take me to see it you're the best mom
ever hmm
Mortal Kombat annihilation
one of the worst sequels ever made the
first one wasn't even really all that
great either it was the first movie
directed by Paul WS Anderson and some
still say it might be his best movie
Mortal Kombat annihilation makes that
movie look like a bonafide classic this
movie features some of the worst special
effects ever put the screen and some of
the most idiotic fight scenes I've ever
seen it is one of the most hilariously
bad movies ever made it is truly a
hilarious attea movie that is such an
atrocity it's hilarious
so let's talk about it today on my
hilarious 'ti review of Mortal Kombat
annihilation it's okay
I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark I love my eyes I
didn't miss anything
that's what time
Mortal Kombat annihilation this is a
film that actually made us miss Paul WS
Anderson a rare feat this movie came out
in 1997 and I can tell you even at its
release date we were sitting in that
theater going what is with these
horrible special effects they look just
as bad when that movie first came out it
was absurd it looked like a beast wars
television show I used to watch Beast
Wars but that was a TV show Saturday
mornings for children this was a feature
film these special effects are like
Superman for a quest for peace and this
movie came out 10 years after Superman
for did I mean there are moments in this
movie where you can literally see a
white outline around the bodies of these
people on these green screens it's
absurdly awful so one of the things I'm
going to be doing in this hilarious 'ti
review is a flip count that's right
there is an absurd amount of back flips
and front flips and side flips in this
movie and you're watching and you're
like wow I think on the application for
this movie he just said hey can you do a
flip anyway ever yes I can you are hired
at the end of this video I'm going to
count down how many actual flips are in
this movie and I will tell you because
it's pretty awesome so the movie starts
out and there really is no point in
talking about a plot too much during
this video because the plot of this
movie isn't really there it's just like
a whole bunch of people kind of say
things and then they fight but the movie
opens pretty much immediately with one
of the best lines in the movie where the
characters that I'm gonna refer to as
the Bride of Frankenstein says too bad
you will die too bad you are in this
movie so all these people start fighting
and you're like who are these people
again because if you didn't see the
first movie like the day before you have
no idea what's going on because these
characters are like so huge and look at
me I am the most ultimate leader of
MORTAL KOMBAT characters are let's all
fight and have an army of ninjas
remember that army of ninjas remember
them I will get to that soon as long as
the portal remains open your world
becomes my world
okay so we don't know what's going on
let's talk about the actual fight
choreography right because really the
only reason anyone watches a movie like
Mortal Kombat annihilation is to see
some cool fights right every single
stunt in this movie feels faked and
every single shot feels cut at the most
crucial moment in which possible harm
may be done to one of these actors and
the shot is then turned to fake a stunt
in the worst way that's the best way I
can describe the majority of the fights
in this movie they're all completely
emotionless some of them very slow and
they're cut at just the right moment
before a stunt double might actually
have to do something difficult so Johnny
Cage gets killed and Shao Kahn declares
the earth is going to be destroyed in
six days why six days I guess to give
them time to prepare because why else
would you destroy the earth other than
to give your opponent six days to train
and figure out a way to make you not be
able to destroy the earth
that's just what evil people do they
allow people time to train and so they
kind of take their time as they flee
from his army of ninjas yeah they're
just kind of going about their day
they're just kind of taking a nice
little jog they're not really that
worried about dying then Raiden suddenly
shoots lightning from his hand at them
and it like crushes a wall and they
can't get through so what you can shoot
lightning from your hands why didn't you
just electrocute his entire army of
ninjas when they were running at you
that might have been a good idea so now
we see that Shao Kahn is actually the
shapeshifter from the x-files we get a
dialogue scene it's not important it's a
time waster all I'm saying about these
dialogue scenes is that they're filler
that's all they are it's like the
creators of this movie were like okay
look we're gonna have a whole bunch of
fight scenes right but we have to have
this movie be at least like 90 minutes
long so we'll just put some of those
those talking scenes in between you know
where people say things from their
mouths and then we'll put them in
between the fight scenes and none of it
seems to make sense
so Liu Kang and katana are walking
somewhere we don't really know where
they're walking at some film set and
they're being filmed that's all I know
they're about to kiss but meta predator
gets in the way and they have to fight
this guy yes I know this guy's
Mortal Kombat character but I don't care
he's met a predator for this video so
sub-zero saves them but apparently it's
not sub-zero it's sub-zero's brother who
resembles Nicolas Cage I just thought
this movie would be better with me in it
do you have any buddies around I tried
to put on my bear suit but it didn't fit
today so I'm wearing this blue outfit do
you guys like it I like it too
so scorpion appears and he says get over
here in a desperate attempt to make fans
actually like this movie so Liu Kang
does one of his magical flips that
happens a lot in this movie where he
just does his flip and just somehow
catapults himself forward in time I
don't know how he does that but if he
could do that why they need sub-zero to
make a bridge for him if he can just
backflip across the entire thing with
his magic so scorpion steals katana and
says this is a Looney Tunes episode so
Raiden and Sonya Blade noticed this
happening on earth so I guess the two
realms are combining destroying earth
where is humanity throughout this entire
thing you never once see Humanity during
this movie you just see monuments and
landmarks that resemble things you may
know from like New York or Paris
there's no time in this movie where you
actually feel a lean type of fear at all
for humans because you never see humans
you never see a person going oh my god
there's a giant thing in the sky never
once just like six Mortal Kombat
characters and you're supposed to care
about earth for some reason because we
live on earth so Sonia finds Jax he has
these metal arms and she tells them
about the destruction of earth and all
this stuff how am I supposed to follow
this plot I played the games when I was
a kid and I don't know what any of this
incoherent crap is doing a lot of this
movie looks like they were trying to
make it be in 3d where things just
popping out and everything like they
actually were trying to make a
three-dimensional movie without the 3d
glasses I mean every single shot in this
fight is just so horribly done
throughout the entire movie the fights
look awful there's this shot in this
fight where he's supposed to be breaking
the glass with his hands but you don't
even see it make contact with it because
as I said they cut this shot right
before the difficult thing takes place
that's what they do throughout this
movie watch it and you'll understand
throughout this fight Sonya seems
absolutely invincible she can hit
everything no one hits her Jax can't do
a damn thing and when he finally hits
somebody we are reminded that these
fictional butt-kicking
fantasy characters use Street insults
but then the body leaves a self-destruct
explosion that is eminent what does that
remind you of like that explosion though
oh my gosh just look at that think
that's the best thing I've ever seen in
my life that is the worst crane screen
imaginable no as I said I know these
mortal kombat characters I know their
names but these two guys are gonna be
known as Spider Woman and goat boy for
this video that's what I'm gonna call
them and they have the argument scene
and this happens show that again please
show it again oh that's the best thing
I've seen all day
so of course this guy Shao Kahn is the
now cliched villain who kills members of
his own army Darth Vader did it but it
was great because that movie had depth
and interesting characters and you
actually understood why this guy was so
mad Shao Kahn what is this guy he's just
a cliche villain who would want to serve
on his army he messed up once you die so
then we cut to Luke hang on a desert and
you're like oh my gosh
are they actually filming on a real
location
don't worry two shots later you're back
on some shitty set so then something
pops out at him and you're like what is
that and then this is what they do okay
this is their filmmaking technique this
is one of the parts in this movie that I
can't believe happened because look I
can understand crappy green-screen you
just can't afford it I can understand
bad acting and bad writing they don't
have the talent they didn't have the
screenplay
I can understand bad directing but not
so far as this shot he's holding on the
camera going like this with the camera
and that's supposed to be him fighting
with whatever is on him that's how they
decided to film it let's have him fight
with the camera and really crappy slow
motion slow framerate and that will look
awesome right No
so the Indian in the cupboard shows up
and
I should probably clarify that joke I
guess it's the actor from the movie the
Indian in the cupboard
his name is Lightfoot okay
he tells Liu Kang that he needs to learn
what his animality is so that he can
defeat Shao Kahn what did he do
thanks for the plot exposition he knocks
out Liu Kang and then we get a
drug-induced acid trip in which all of
his friends insult him there are 15
people in this house and you're the only
one who has to make trouble look what
you did you little jerk
Kevin you are such a disease Kevin I'm
going to feed you to my tarantula so
some chick named Jade visits him in the
snow what the hell is this I guess he
has to go through like three challenges
the penitent man will pass the penitent
man will pass
Indiana Jones in the Last Crusade
another movie this is trying to rip off
so then we got another fight scene with
the fakest rock ever I mean look at that
are they even trying are they even
trying let me cut to Raiden and he's
walking around the desert with his arms
out and he's looking all holy and
everything and you know what it reminds
me of that Britney Spears music video
so he has to ask the gods three
questions he only gets three questions
what if something like really bad was
going on and you couldn't cover it in
three questions like I don't know maybe
the earth being destroyed so the four of
them meet up and Sonia is mad for some
reason what's she mad about I don't
understand I mean yeah the earth is
being destroyed but she seems very upset
at Luke hang in them and she doesn't
even know why she's just supposed to be
upset because more than likely in the
screenplay it said Sonia angry and
parenthesis and then her line what's she
angry about but don't worry because
Radin his back and he enters with a
magical backflip
never give up hope so as Raiden opens a
portal to their world we see Shao Kahn
with his humongous army and Bride of
Frankenstein of course now remember that
army remember it Raiden and the rest of
the Mortal Kombat crew get into their
world safely where everything is purple
there's landmarks all over the place
from the earth as I said that's the only
way we know the humanities in trouble we
see the Eiffel Tower that's how we know
that they were in trouble so everyone
starts fighting in the giant climactic
Mortal Kombat annihilation fight that we
were waiting for and then there's a
dodge kicking fight because that's
apparently how two people make progress
as their fighting is continuously dodge
eachother by kicking back and forth over
and over again so suddenly the Bride of
Frankenstein is dead and it's so obvious
that Jade is evil in hiding I mean you'd
have to be an idiot not to notice this
it's the most obvious thing like yeah
you're obviously bad just turn bad
already so we can move on with the plot
please so Liu Kang finds katana she's
all trapped and everything and then a
crazy monster guy swings in and she's
like it's a trap leave you think that
maybe you should have said that before
the crazy monster guy swung in so Lu
Kang fights this monster guy on top of
this thing and look how slow and
emotionless this fight is so Spider
Woman whips Raiden with her hair and
then the obvious twist with Jade is
revealed and now she has Vulcan eyebrows
because she is evil now so due to budget
constraints Spider Woman dies very
abruptly you think I'm joking that's
actually true yeah she gets crushed by
something because they couldn't afford
to animate her arms anymore
you think I'm joking I'm not that's
actually what it is so now we get more
pointless drivel bs we're plot points
get revealed how cut is my brother oh my
gosh they're brothers
I don't care at all and credits happen
already so a giant burping creature eats
Jade and again how much does it suck to
work for this guy he kills everyone on
his side so apparently the only way that
Lu can can defeat Shao Kahn is if he
just fights him by himself why can't
they all team up on him why can't they
all just help o cuz there's more people
there still goat boy Dan go boy and then
the the fight happens and all people are
fighting it's a movie for Shao Kahn
blasts Raiden once and then he's like I
win Brava
really what do you got the gold pp7 from
Goldeneye 64 where you get the one-shot
kill what is this thing one hit kills
this guy but then we get the animality
scene yeah cuz Liu Kang has to remember
his animality remember that they turn
into these creatures it looks like I
created it on a Macintosh in 1992 in
elementary school when I was like hey
look at this program I can make oh cool
I can make little shapes and features
Wow Hey look teacher I can make little
shapes and features that's great
Wow Chris you should become a special
effects designer for a movie about five
years from now and then you can end your
career because your special effects suck
you get an a-plus today so now that
they've finally killed all the other
characters they simply watch Liu Kang as
he fights Shao Kahn without helping at
all you know it is entirely possible
that the added advantage of more people
fighting your enemy would assist but
they don't they just watch now look I've
been saying something for a while that I
would get to a certain point and here it
is where is his army where the ninjas
from the beginning of the movie where's
the army those with him in the desert
they're never seen or heard from again
they have nothing to do with the battle
they were just there to be an army and
then they didn't do anything there's
even a scene where he's instructing his
army like the undercover and we're
to win and blah blah blah the army never
shows up why I don't know budget
constraints probably because that's what
this entire movie has against it is
budget constraints
so eventually Liu Kang and Shao Kahn
fall down and they're magically people
again they're no longer there animality
form because more than likely the budget
ran out for that type of special effect
that I made in the Macintosh in 1992
okay I'm done and the two magical old
people appear I guess they're the gods
or whatever and they declare mortal
combat between Shao Kahn and Liu Kang I
guess that whole finding your animality
thing had nothing to do with anything
and actually didn't help at all it was
just hey look at these special effects
we made Shao Kahn gets knocked down but
then he screams knew before Liu Kang
defeats him how was this a victory if
this evil guy who wants to destroy the
planet is still alive I don't really
understand actually his father gets
trapped in the Phantom Zone from
Superman then all these flash has
happened and we get some footage of the
landmarks that were coming through the
realms being just fine but you can tell
that it's something called stock footage
in other words some way or in a computer
somewhere someone had a shot of the
Golden Gate Bridge someone had a shot of
Paris and like let's just put this in
the movie and you can so tell that is
just stock footage it's so sad they
couldn't even go and take him again
where was the damn army army so everyone
just gets instantly and conveniently
zapped back to earth bride of
Frankenstein's okay now
Raiden's a god why did the gods lie to
him because he seems to be thinking that
gods lied to him why did that happen
none of it really matters because it's a
movie where people are supposed to fight
and have techno music and the fight
scenes don't even work so they all smile
about it and walk away that's the ending
of this movie that's the end of this
movie
they smile about it and walk away I just
turned into very angry Yoda I didn't
mean to do that
alright so as I promised at the
beginning of this video I was gonna do a
lip count there's a lot of flips in this
movie trust me you want to know how many
there are 54 54 back flips front flips
side flips whatever flips there's 54 of
them that's all they had to offer this
movie was a whole bunch of flips Mortal
Kombat annihilation is a joke it is a
movie that is so bad that it is good and
you can watch it with your friends and
enjoy yourselves because it's just so
incredible that a movie like this
actually gets made it was put into
theaters and fans went and saw and we're
like at least that was my reaction guys
thanks so much as always for watching my
Hillary asti reviews I'll be back very
soon with more of them I'm really
enjoying doing this and I'm glad you
guys are too thanks as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes